josée legault hélène budget ti michel
david bonsoir je veux entendre ce qui
n'était pas avec nous au tout début
d'émission monsieur legault jeudi baisse
si la tendance se maintient mais il y en
aura pas de rassemblement des côtes
je être transparent puis josé la vérité
aux québécois actuellement on voit pas
dans la bonne direction le nombre
d'hospitalisations
s'ils continuent à augmenter comme on
voit actuellement malheureusement ça
sera pas possible d'avoir les deux
rassemblements à noël mais je le répète
la décision n'est pas prise on va
prendre la décision le 11 décembre
bon josée legault pour vous j'imagine
c'est une évidence que compte-tenu pas
tellement le nombre de cas s'assume
changent mais le nombre
d'hospitalisations et le poids que ça
fait peser sur le réseau de la santé
pour vous ça doit être une évidence que
il faut plus de prudence que moi oui
surtout en regard de ce qui pourrait
suivre en janvier si justement la
prudence n'est pas de mise donc cette
troisième vague dont plusieurs experts
parlent déjà je pense que
l'avertissement il est vraiment là et on
voit très bien lorsque le premier
ministre commence à faire flotter cette
possibilité le corps est qu'il n'y
aurait pas de rassemblement c'est que
justement s'il y en avait ce qui aurait
payé d'ailleurs le gouvernement a
toujours reconnu qu'il y aurait un prix
à payer c'est que là le système de santé
n'a pas les moyens de payer ce prix là
et moi je reprend la formule date
acteurs cécile trambly quand on est
discret aux deux semaines déjà alors à
noël fête est petit ça veut dire son
propre ménage sa propre adresse
pour le reste c'est très dur mais on a
quand même des moyens technologiques
pour pouvoir rester en contact avec les
proches qu'on aime qu'on pourra pas voir
si tel est le cas et
noël 2021 ça va être ça hélène hier la
scientifique en chef nous disait ma mère
aussi la même chose lors d'autres mots à
10h le rester dans votre foyer familial
pour cette année puis il y en aura
d'autres je comprends que c'est lourd
mais en même temps on veut pas le poids
trop lourd pour le système de santé sans
que ce soit et des provinces aussi
qu'ils l'ont déjà dit mais il faut quand
même se rappeler que monsieur legault
avait fait cette promesse qu'on pourrait
avoir noël parce que c'était s'appuyer
sur un contrat social et peut-être que
les gens n'ont pas compris que le
contrat social commencer dès maintenant
qu'il fallait réduire nos contacts
maintenant pour aplatir la fameuse
courbe est peut-être enfin célébrer noël
ceci dit je me pose la question c'est
facile de dire les québécois ne respecte
pas le contrat social le nombre de cas
augmente mais en même temps je me
demande est ce que c'est vraiment le
vrai puisque on voit que la situation se
détériore beaucoup aussi dans l'east et
h et celle des donc est ce que ma mère
oui exactement aussi est-ce que donc est
ce que c'est parce que les gens n'ont
pas respecté le contrat social ou que
encore une fois les mesures n'ont pas
été bien mis en place dans ces endroits
là où il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées
je me pose la question je juge j'ai pas
encore tranché mais c'est certain que il
faut maintenant réduire les contacts si
on veut avoir ce contact de noël ou un
michel david
ouais ça fait déjà quelques jours que
monsieur legault là commence à habituer
l'opinion a finalement au fait que le
contrat moral ou être déchirés il y en
avait parlé un peu la semaine dernière
il est plus affirmatif et je pense que
au départ je me suis dit si jamais il
faut qu'ils reviennent sa décision ça ça
va être politiquement très dommageable
pour lui mais j'ai l'impression que
l'opinion publique qui fait aussi la
joie y ait un sondage pensent qu'une
majorité de québécois qui sont plutôt
d'accord pour ne pas fêter noël cette
année et il ya tellement d'experts de
tous côtés vous écoutez ça serait une
folie que je pense que ça percole dans
l'opinion publique et finalement les
gens vont faisait bon ben coudonc c'est
la décision à prendre
oui beaucoup à peu près tous nos experts
et quand je dis nous c'est la presse en
général qu'aux juges chênois radio
canada qui disent attention le soyons
plus prudent que - comme parce qu'on
veut pas en janvier est repris des
hôpitaux parce que c'est le manque de
personnel c'est pas juste s'ils avaient
par magie 10000 15000 personnes de plus
dans les réseaux hospitaliers
à la limite on pourrait s'y installent
mais c'est pas le cas josé non pas du
tout il ya aussi des vies en jeu parce
que les gens continuent de mourir de 7,2
de cette saloperie de virus ya donc il
ya des vies à protéger il ya des gens
qui tombent malades qui en meurent pas
mais qui ont de graves séquelles qui
peuvent en avoir trail très longtemps
donc c'est tout ça va ensemble et et
l'importance enfin la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite que le 11 décembre
premier ministre dise clairement
écoutez pas de rassemblement c'est que
l'importance d'une consigne comme ça
c'est sûr qu'il y aura jamais une
adhésion à 100 pour ça mais ça va
assurer une adhésion supérieur que
contrairement si les six avaient dit oui
bon rassemblement ou deux parce que là
les gens se serait il ya des gens qui se
seraient sentis bon des douaniers donc
on va en échappée il ya des gens qui
vont fêter quand même
mais l'important c'est qu'il y en ait le
moins possible voilà transferts en santé
hélène michel david joseph entend deux
extrêmes ce trudeau et monsieur legault
on a parlé de des investissements sans
précédent qu'on a fait dans les systèmes
de santé pour aider les provinces
on parle d'un milliard de dollars
directement les provinces en plus des
transferts de santé habituels
on parle de 25 milliards de dollars pour
les la relance sécuritaire au total on
les investissements reliés à la santé
on parle d'une hausse de presque 25%
ce qu'on valait négocier le 10 décembre
cela-dit dans les prochaines années vous
avez plus de marge de manoeuvre que les
provinces vous devriez contribuer
davantage que 22% au transfert canadien
en santé donc ça va c'est le seul sujet
le transfert canadien s'il veut vraiment
nous aider dans les ch celle des deux
hôpitaux dans tout le réseau de la santé
il faut qu'ils nous envoient un signal
qui est prêt à augmenter sa contribution
récurrents récurrents michel david qui a
le gros bout du bâton coin je pensais
gouvernement fédéral parce que d'abord
c'est lui qui décide
en bout de ligne et d'autre part je suis
pas convaincu moi que les canadiens sont
son commentaire carrément derrière les
provinces tout le monde reconnaît qu'il
faut plus d'argent en santé mais
comme par exemple quand monsieur trudeau
dit on a mis beaucoup d'argent
dans le dans la santé durant la pandémie
les gens d or et c'est vrai et d'autre
part moi je pense encore que l'on va
assister au scénario habituel c'est à
dire que monsieur trudeau va réussir à
briser le front commun des provinces et
qu'éventuellement je pense qu'il va y
avoir une petite augmentation dames et
l'on parle de 28 milliards par année
c'est tout à fait impensable qu'elle est
froide et legault ensemble 6 yens 100 m
ça commence à faire du monde
oui c'est vrai mais au départ il est à
dix ou si la dernière ronde de
négociation souvient vous puis elle a
fait le québec s'est retrouvé tout
barrette s'est retrouvé tout seul et je
crains qu'encore une fois ce soit ceux
qui se produisent parce que y'a moyen de
faire des arrangements différents avec
des provinces écoutez bon là il y aura
patienté mais vous savez votre projet là
que vous avez ça il ya peut-être moyen
de participer à ça alors je pense qu'il
va y avoir encore une grosse déception
en bout de ligne donc oui j'étais assez
d'accord je dois dire que ça me fait un
peu rigoler quand j'entends des la
situation de monsieur legault qui dit
c'est à ottawa plus de marge de
manoeuvre que dans les provinces pour
avoir eu la mise à jour économique hier
avant les chiffres de déficit
je suis pas sûr de voir beaucoup de
visages de marge de manoeuvre à ce
moment là des députés de 400 milliards
et chez perrault moi ce que j'ai décoder
des propos de monsieur trudeau
aujourd'hui quand il nous disait
maintenant il le répéter le mot
maintenant plusieurs fois ma priorité
c'est de nous faire passer à travers la
crise
on verra ensuite moi ça me donne l
impression que de l'argent dans les
transferts en santé
maintenant il n'y en aura pas donc cette
rencontre l'ol sera à mon avis très
décevante d'ailleurs dans la mise à jour
qui nous ont été présentés hier on n'a
pas prévu de mon temps additionnel pour
la santé alors j'ai l'impression que
monsieur trudeau mots nous remettre à
plus tard
et si jamais il devait y avoir des
petits grenat et distribué ici et là les
provinces devront prendre garde qu'il
n'y a pas des conditions attachées à ce
déjà dans cette mise à jour on nous
promet un milliard de dollars pour les
résidences pour personnes âgées
les achats celle d être généreux et ça
s'accompagne de conditions il faudra
dresser des critères nous dit on et
ottawa va verser l'argent seulement
quand il aura la preuve que ces critères
l'autre ont bien été rencontrés çà en
risque de faire fâcher beaucoup les
promesses mais cette perte est un modèle
qui sera produit
josé oui mais c'est très délicat comme
opération sur le plan politique pour
monsieur legault parce que bon sur le
fond il a tout à fait raison c'est
cesser les provinces ont besoin d'un
financement récurrent le chiffre est
aujourd'hui clairement 6 milliards de
dollars par année récurrent pour le
québec seulement sans conditions puisque
la santé de juridiction provinciale
bon on peut faire un colloque
universitaire là dessus on peut en
discuter longtemps mais dans la
population il reste que au québec dans
les chu celle dés la première vague
était très très meurtrière et on n'a pas
besoin de revenir sur toutes les raisons
donc 7 7 7
cet intérêt que monsieur trudeau mon
autre sud helmand pour les soins de
longue durée
ça vient aussi de ça et si monsieur
legault échoue évidemment donc soit que
les provinces aux divisions entre de
toute façon si ça se termine sur une fin
de non recevoir comme premier ministre
d'un gouvernement nationaliste mais
fédéraliste ça va être quand même
méchant mur qui va avoir frappé et donc
comment il va l'expliquer aux québécois
ça je le sais pas mais disons que
leurs rapports de force du québec et non
seulement il faut qu'il trouve une
conséquence sinon bah écoutez c'est
parce que là c'est tellement important
qu'on va sortir de cette pandémie nos un
jour et puis on le voit au québec le
livre d'eli coûts en santé là il ya
quelque chose qui marche pas parce que
c'est un puits sans fond alors c'est pas
juste une question d'argent c'est une
question d'organisation question qui est
vital pour monsieur leubou non seulement
parce que le système de santé va
continuer à coûter de plus en plus cher
mais il la contribution augmenter du
grand fédéral c'est pas mal la condition
du retour à de la route vers l'
équilibre que monsieur legault a dessiné
comme ceux giral devrait signer dans sa
maison escompté ben voilà alors là tout
où tous les veaux vaches cochons couvées
l'oci si l'argent du fédéral est pas là
ça va donner
alors si dans ces règles sur le groupe
voudrait négocier que monsieur o'toole
par exemple que fera t-il avec le bloc
michel vous avez un bon texte ce matin
alors on va attendre d'abord monsieur
trudeau qui nous parle de vote de
confiance parce qu'un énoncé économique
une loi précise king ou aux dépenses
d'argent normalement ça va deux
confiants mais est l'un d'entre eux
écoutez bien monsieur trudeau convient
par les deux seuls du jeu politique qui
va s'ouvrir
m
est-ce qu'il s'est raclé la gorge je me
suis plutôt du cac après avoir dit on
n'en veut pas vraiment d'élections
parce que ce que vous disiez michel puis
c'est que stratégiquement ce serait
peut-être une bonne idée qui en est plus
vite que plus tard pour lui
oui je pense qu'actuellement à monsieur
trudeau bénéficie le plaisir de la
pandémie savais que les gens voient que
le gouvernement fédéral investit
beaucoup les gens sont sont corrects
sont contents mais au fur et à mesure où
on va voir le tunnel après la fin du
tunnel approcher la préoccupation des
gens va passer de la santé à l'économie
et le gouvernement le parti libéral
devrait dire et est perçu comme le
meilleur parti pour relancer l'économie
ce sont les conservateurs qui ont là qui
ont qui ont la cote actuellement à ce
chapitre est là alors oui monsieur
trudeau je pense aimerait bien avoir des
élections le plus vite possible
maintenant je doute que les partis
d'opposition le renverse le projet de
loi à moins qu'il fasse exprès là pour
se faire renverser mais par exemple je
pense pas que dans le projet doit on va
on va retrouver l'histoire des normes
nationales qui font grimper le blog d'un
rideau
et à tout événement je pense le npd va
voter à appuyer le gouvernement
oui il m c'est ça non je pense pas parce
que avant noël je pense pas de personnes
peuvent aller en élections mais monsieur
trudeau j'aurais dit deux mois plus tôt
qu'il voulait y aller mais là je pense
que je garderai une petite gêne et ils
vont attendre au printemps qui est à se
défaire lui-même pour exactement les
raisons qui ont évoqué michel mai et le
npd
monsieur jack meeting le chef nous a dit
aujourd'hui qu'il n'était pas intéressé
à une élection donc j'ai tout porte à
croire que le il sera encore une fois le
sauveur de monsieur trudeau et ceci
explique selon parlé tout à l'heure de
normes nationales de conditions imposées
aux provinces dans des domaines de
strictement provinciaux eh bien monsieur
singh c'est le genre de truc qui le
branche est le genre de chose qui le
demandent des conditions aux provinces
il est dans la même veine même que le
parti vert même si parti vert n'est pas
stratégique dans ce jeu minoritaire mais
parti vert qui demandent constamment des
normes nationales et posé une vision
nationale dans la lutte à cette pandémie
alors là le statut minoritaire de
monsieur trudeau la merde à avoir des
inclinations néo-démocrates et donc
intrusive auprès des provinces changé et
su aussi c'est la fibre des trudeau
aussi quand même quelque part ces
territoires par là mais il ya aussi le
problème de des vaccins parce que bon là
ça branle un petit peu dans la manche on
a cette inquiétude locke aux etats-unis
dans certains pays européens et cetera
les gens vont se faire vacciner avant
que l'on recommence pour les canadiens
donc ça c'est très délicat pour monsieur
trudeau aussi donc je suis fou qu'il
accélère donc on commence à parler
peut-être de janvier bon c'est pas trop
et monsieur legault aujourd'hui parlait
de bons de 700 mille doses qui viendrait
au québec d'ici la fin du mois de mars
mais il est dit mais kaka alors le cas
ça va être un élément très important sur
désolé de le dire c'est pas du cynisme
le m électoralement parlant le plus
rapidement il va pouvoir livrer des
vaccins
canadien le mieux il s'emportait
électoralement voilà merci beaucoup à
vous trois méch s intéressant on va
reparler la prochaine fois je dis le
gouffre quand même quand elle peut pas
largué le bloc là il peut pas dire jeux
wii allons-y pour concernant des civils
mais y est pas obligé de l'appuyer aussi
aussi évidemment que la dernière fois ce
que voudrait bien voir autour pour
d'amener des gains c'est à sa population
aimerait bien voir un premier ministre
qui lui donne des choses absolument
parce que monsieur legault va aussi
aller en élections dans deux ans et il
va falloir qu'il dise j'ai regardé ce
que j'ai obtenu jusqu'à ce rezaï obtient
rien un petit hameau et la nature
ça te dit qu'il ne poserait pas de
conditions aux transferts en santé mais
s'est jamais engagé à les augmenter
je vous rappellerai que ces mesures un
peu qu'ils les avaient plafonné à 3 % la
partie de ce côté là c'est certain
qu'ils avaient débloqué à mener merci
beaucoup merci merci à très bientôt